hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you checking in
to see how your weeks gone before I get
started this is going to be a special
podcast so I have a couple of special
amount announcements Steven Adler is
back together with Adler's appetite and
they're gonna be playing at the the Rose
in Pasadena on August 23rd and then he's
going to be in Vegas at the Golden
Nugget on the 24th and on the 25th this
is August August 8th at the Canyon Club
in Santa Clarita if you want to see one
of the best drummers I've ever seen in
my life check out Adler's appetite we'll
have a link and all that type of stuff
go out and go check out jeez I forgot to
promote a couple of things alright
number one I'm gonna be at Madison
Square Garden November 7th for the New
York Comedy Festival tickets are on sale
now I believe that's a Wednesday hump
day everybody and I didn't read the one
read I had Hubbell everybody do you have
eyes do they not work as well as they
should do you like spending less money
on things more than more money on things
do you know what the internet is if you
answered yes to any or all these
questions then visit Hubble contacts
calm motivate your audience choose one
or two all right I guess these are
positive things talk about how you've
been wearing Hubble contacts for the
past 25 years I have it before I didn't
see things and now I see I didn't wear
those [ __ ] things I don't have
contacts I have no idea I don't want
this saying these guys make contact
lenses and they're [ __ ] great how is
that with humble you'll get a fresh pair
of lenses for every single day for less
than 60 for less 60 contacts for 33
bucks do the math that's barely a dollar
a day this is way more affordable than
other brands go to Hubble contacts comm
and get your first two weeks for free
Hubble sells directly to you so they can
for context at a more affordable price
they can send you to an optometrist if
you don't have a prescription featured
in vogue GQ TechCrunch Mashable and now
the Monday morning podcast or Thursday
afternoon just before Friday so do what
I evidently did 100% and go to Hubble
contacts comm and get your first two
weeks of lenses for free
that's hu be ble contacts calm and with
that the other announcement I have to
make I have a very special guest a long
time waiting a long time in the coming
four whatever whatever [ __ ] reason
we've hung out a million times we never
thought to do a podcast I don't want to
infringe on the Mansa talents please
welcome mr. Tom Rhodes yay what's going
hey from me what's up brother how are
you brother um I'm doing good man I'm so
psyched you're in a podcast you're one
of the one of the best comics I know
I've known you feel like I know I've
known you for like 20 I don't know how
many miles yeah yeah way back in LA and
I would say I was living in New York
like 98 99 was that it I think maybe
that was what it was I thought I met you
in like 95 or 96 out here in LA who's
out here yeah mainly briefly you
probably walked by with your romantic
novel hair that you had back that
romance novel haircut I mean with my red
afro two hacks passing in the night
right trying to get better and then yeah
then I I think the first time I
officially kind of met you was hanging
out back when we both had phallic
strength yes and I was very excited that
you knew who I was because I had seen
you at eating it of all places which is
why I became a huge fan of your stand-up
I've told you this story before imma
tell the listeners were you were you
were talking about some sort of
extracurricular activity that you were
doing I had done mushrooms in Amsterdam
and Vondelpark yes and I just remember
you describing the whole [ __ ] trip of
it and just remember you would just at
one point you were just like I was
running through the grass on my
tippy-toes and it's just something about
that was like you know there's nothing
with alcohol there's nothing worse than
just seeing somebody who's like
completely [ __ ] up but like with
mushrooms this like a oneness with the
world where you literally watch an adult
become a child there's something I just
thought you described it I've never
taken mushrooms but like from what I've
seen when I've seen people trip in it
and I was there with with Nia way back
in the day when we was still
boyfriend/girlfriend and we would die in
laughing and that became like you know
like one of the catchphrase for us you
know we would just be walking around the
apartment one would be in the other room
we would just would just yell that out
vetoes we both would just start laughing
that's the greatest compliment you could
get when like a joke or a sentence from
a joke becomes part of somebody's
vernacular you know oh yeah there's been
a few there's the Dave Chappelle
Dave Chappelle had a bit about how you
know he likes eating chicken and he's a
black dude so there's that weird sort of
stereotype he's like but up but I like
it he goes but I won't eat it in public
because he goes I'm afraid there'll be
some white people around going look at
him he loves it so just like the
Encyclopedia says it wasn't that the
last line of that bit I don't remember I
just remember this day I know I can't do
this Jane without thinking to that line
well to this day when me and India are
hanging out
before eating food enough if she go as a
taste I go it's good I like it and she
just go look at him he loves it like it
just it's just it was a few of those
loves it
yeah now I got to go through all of them
Sarah Silverman Sarah Silverman said
something about how she always
practicums or something I think I always
remember there was a punch line was
because I do a lot of [ __ ] and I mean
Nia was watching that we're in this
little one-bedroom apartment and is
everything is in New York little and I
was shaving in the other room and I just
heard the I didn't really hear the setup
which probably I can't remember but I
just bursted out laughing while I was
shaving so anyway you're part of my
Mount Rushmore of lines that just never
it just never left my my my head I don't
know why so and furthermore other you
know I would say either you or Doug
Stanhope
have probably put the most like stand up
miles on the odometer as far as the
places that that you've played how
far you've gone but I mean you might
have to be the king man you were telling
me that at some point in this podcast
you were gonna start rattling off your
dates if actually you sat down here
looking like you didn't have a care in
the world and you just casually
mentioned to me that you're off to
Mongolia tomorrow yeah yeah I would be a
[ __ ] wreck going like oh I would am I
going to forget something I would have
to check 50 times to make sure I have my
passport and I would stick in the bag
and I would zip it shut and then look to
make sure it I would zip it shut again
and then I would still have to check it
before I left the house in the car on
the way to the airport before I started
talking that anxiety down because I used
is my jenga's Khan biography to reread
on the plane that's it then how you say
it's not gay yeah I played in Mongolia
last October and it was freezing it was
in the third so this is you're the only
guy I know not only been to Mongolia
over notice to his return engagement
triumphant return tomorrow awesome the
comedians they're wonderful guys I mean
in Mongolians are beautiful man they
look like that the people in Avatar but
without the blue and five of the low
five of the local Mongolian comedians
met me at the airport when I arrived and
they jump out they cheered when I came
out I'm like the most famous comedian
that's ever played in Mongolia so they
like bent over backwards it's showing me
all on guitar and we drove out to the
the world's largest Jenga scone statue
and yeah they taught me that it's it's
Jenga scone not just Angus and those
those well I thought you're not
obnoxious with that information you
could be really kunti at a party excuse
me guys I don't interrupt its janga
scone yeah an Americans and other people
say though they call those white round
tents yurts but they actually call them
Gers and Mongolia so what's what's the I
don't know anything about it other than
it's just sort of spoons with northern
China it's between em and Robin China
and Russia and so I liked it so much and
I wanted to go back in summer and see it
when it wasn't bone-chilling cold so
it's kind of
a vacation so I mean I'm gonna do a gig
there but I'm gonna go into I'm gonna
spend like four days there these guys
gonna take me way out into the country
we're gonna sleep in a ger one of those
round tents what the life shoot some
arrows do some do some Mongolian warrior
activities and then I got a gig
you got a cell Rogan about this Rogan
sounds like he would be although I'm
sure you would love it I'm sure you
would love it it's um you know that's
the I've shot some arrows in my time I
went I went both fishing and some Bayou
down and [ __ ] our with hell was
somewhere outside of New Orleans it's a
great thing about being a comedian
remember I was in Alaska years ago I did
a gig in Ketchikan and I met the perfect
Alaskan guy who took me fishing on his
charter boat and then took me skeet
shooting I always feel like when you
meet those guys there's always some sort
of like raggedy plane you get in first
that lands on water or they put
snowshoes on bottom of it plates a
pontoon so what let's see you know
you're the only guy I know that's played
Vietnam I love Vietnam you know my my
view I know that watches like Ken Burns
documentary is like yeah I've been there
yeah I've played there yeah I know what
it looks like no I've done all of that I
know well I did that special for Comedy
Central in 1995 called Viva Vietnam I
were I got to go to Vietnam you've been
going I was like years you know I was
the first comedian ever to have a
development deal with Comedy Central and
so I could do whatever I wanted it was
like being a junior film maker almost so
oh it was 1994 Bill Clinton lifted the
travel ban on Vietnam the way like Obama
lifted the travel ban on Cuba and my
father fought in Vietnam II flew
helicopters he was shot down everyone in
this helicopter can you tell that story
yeah quickly yeah so and this is why
Vietnam has always been really important
it's been a big thing in our family so
my father flew helicopters in Vietnam in
1969 he was stationed and Pleiku
and I he there was there was all these
soldiers stuck on the ground there
surrounded by the North Vietnamese
soldiers and there they're just getting
slaughtered so my father had to fly in
and rescue these guys how old was um he
actually joined my dad was one of those
knuckleheads so he was 30 his his
buddies in his unit called him
Methuselah because he was like the
oldest guy there cuz everybody else was
19 you know he just thought you know he
grew up on John Wayne movies you thought
that you know he was one of those guys
that talked about how your country
needed you you know so they made he made
I I got the the letter from the army and
all his medals after he died so he made
three attempts to land to save these
guys and was it took so much heavy fire
he had to lift up circle around and on
the fourth attempt he gets down and
there's like 20 guys down there still
alive and it's life or death so they all
like jump on the helicopter and as he's
pulling up you know and he's just
getting rattled with so much fire
machine gun fire that the helicopter
nose dived down and everybody died in
the helicopter except for him and his
copilot who was knocked unconscious he
unhooks him drags him across the field
under heavy fire and then they had to
wait there for like an hour to before
someone could come in and rescue was he
shooting back at them or what well it's
funny he because he you know he my dad
would laugh when he tells the story cuz
he always had this pistol that he would
take with him when he when he was flying
and then the one day he forgot it he
gets shot down so he wasn't shooting
that he didn't have a gun so my dad was
a decorated war hero and he he got like
five medals I bent over the house he tom
has it framed he has the letter and and
there's like you know the little from
the army saying what he did from his
commanding officer and there's almost
not enough room in the frame for all of
the men take five there's like six
medals but five were from that one
incident he got the dish
English flying cross and and my father
is buried in Arlington National Cemetery
as he should be and you got to be a
badass to get in there you know I would
say he qualifies so my dad I'll probably
be buried across the street like one of
a 7-eleven
I want a Viking funeral pyre so so my
dad every year he would get he would
have a reunion with his Vietnam veteran
helicopter buddies it was like a big
thing for him and and and you know my
dad also loved stand-up comedy my dad
loved Pryor and my dad's the reason I'm
a comedian you know he yet all I
remember driving around with as a little
kid listening to Richard Pryor with my
dad so as he thrilled that you became a
comedian oh yeah my dad drove me to my
first open mic night so my dad stand-up
comedy was always revered in my family
and well especially you know because my
dad and he just my dad worshipped Pryor
he had Bob Newhart records and today's a
great taste ooh yeah so I I think those
were like my two biggest influences as a
kid and then my family's from Washington
DC and my uncle did open mic nights for
one year in 1978 I'm 11 years old my dad
took me to see my uncle perform at this
open mic night and it was a club called
El Brookman in DC and the entrance was
next to the stage the shows in progress
we walk in I'm wearing a Washington
Redskins jacket the comedian on stage
pulls me onstage and he starts
interviewing me like I'm the coach of
the Redskins a bashful dopey kid I give
you know the great bit don't more
dancers yes no right but I'll never
forget standing on that stage and seeing
all those happy people with their heads
thrown back and laughter and all the
teeth in their mouth and that moment
changed my life and I you know and I
just yeah I can I can still picture it
you know it's I you know you know black
people Latin people white people like
Asian people just the flavors of
humanity
all right and I just thought that that
was the most magical place in the world
to stand on stage making people laugh so
I became a student of comedy after that
and would keep notebooks and then I
started when I was 17 with a fake idea
you still have all your comedy like you
like your your apartment first of all
it's cooler [ __ ] it's also like this
it's the Smithsonian of your life and he
has his dad's helmet from Vietnam he won
that he was wearing I got chills looking
at that thing
yeah like that's like imagine right now
you brain when he was where'd that yes
and you would told me the story as we
was sitting there smoking a wonderful
cigar and you told me this story and
then to send you well I still have the
helmet and I was like oh wow man I
couldn't believe it then to walk in and
see it an afternoon just the heaviness
of it once there's like a story attached
to it like if you just got a helmet and
it was like yeah this is like a you know
some memorabilia thing this is and you
have to wonder what have to actually
know what happened while that thing was
I mean
I'm into that type of [ __ ] like I got
that weird thing of like if I know this
story behind it which is why I have to
be careful because I'll just fill my
house up with a bunch of [ __ ] like that
and then I have all this [ __ ] anxiety
that I have no place to set anything
down you know I can't have this thing
cuz I kind of grew up with semi hoarders
that just would not [ __ ] throw
anything out you know 40 years of
magazines and [ __ ]
no cool thing about you know I had
everything in storage for 10 years I
just traveled the world I decided not to
live anywhere do you think and so I got
to preserve all these great things you
know but do you think your dad being in
Vietnam and then you learning about that
is that how you got the travel bug to
the level you did your own like some Tom
Brokaw level [ __ ] here maybe and my
mother's from Argentina um so I don't
know I mean I had performed everywhere
in the United States you know 20 30
times and I wanted to branch out but but
but but back to Vietnam I mean that was
a really special thing for me to go
there and I filmed this our special
called Viva Vietnam for Comedy Central I
was I could travel
blog type of thing did the Jane Fonda
workout tape in Hanoi with some old
women in a park that what that did name
China Beach settle if it was a guy
people about why Jane Fonda is funny for
them
IV 't Nam veterans hate Jane Fonda's
guts still to this day veterans at those
Vietnam reunions my dad would go to they
still sell the Jane Fonda urine the
thing for like a urinal guard with her
picture on it you know urinal cake yeah
well no like the little plastic things
on it oh yeah okay they may have a thumb
war Jane Fonda goes to Hanoi the the
capital of the people were having a war
with and she's anti-war and and and they
took pictures of her on like
anti-aircraft artillery and and then she
met the POWs and one of them slipped her
a note and then she apparently if I
remember the story correctly she gave
that to the Vietnamese prison guards and
oh god is tortured extra for slipping
her a note oh god that's right this has
to be the ultimate stupid celebrity
moment yeah where you're you're just so
like you know sucking the dick of your
own [ __ ] ego that you you go and do
something like that to just more than
being against a war is okay that's
conduct you go to the capital and I've
watched enough war movies that my heart
would be in my [ __ ] throat the second
you get the note you like do I got to
put this under my tongue and put it up
my ass like what I got to do you got to
do it I know this is like some
top-secret [ __ ] yeah but so in in 1990
we film a guard that me a note
he'll need extra bamboo under his
fingernails so 19 September 94 we filmed
it and like Americans it was only like
vets that went there like it hadn't
become like a tourist place yet
so in this park in in Hanoi old women
would gather and do Tai Chi in the
morning so at the time in 94 began early
90s Jane Fonda was making these exercise
tapes and we set up a television with a
VCR and we brought the tape and 1994
technology we had to run an extension
cord like five blocks to set this up in
the park and these old women loved it
they took to it and they started doing
it and she turned it she goes now turn
to the right and I'll say I I'll say she
turned to the right did she go did you
see can you imagine her [ __ ] agent
when she was telling him that I'm gonna
go to North Vietnam he's just said that
Jane I've worked so hard with you to get
you to this level I'm imploring you not
to do this Oh Marie Mary Tyler Moore
episode god what a [ __ ] he's sort of
like the first Dennis Rodman like went
by the time Dennis did it it was just
just been so much left first of all they
didn't have our guys you know in in pmw
Kansas yeah and well I mean you know
most guys named otto warmbier it was a
guy that i have no clue who that is did
he play for the Bengals I'm the only one
who remembers this guy's name I think he
was from Chicago he was there he went to
North Korea on vacation a few years ago
and he stole a banner out of the best
kind of hotel yeah and they sent him it
sentenced him to you know hard labor for
life and then they gave back years later
they sent him back as a vegetable there
was in a coma yeah and he died yeah he
died heartbreaking story so yeah he went
up that he went in there like yes uh-huh
it took that post or whatever which is
you know so something you don't do I
remember somebody on the internet was
like please you example a white
privilege oh my god it's just like even
this you have to turn into that yeah
can't we all just be like wow that's
somebody's son yeah
you know can't can't you just do that do
you have to turn it into like a [ __ ]
hashtag social justice whatever
and everyone's being dehumanized yeah I
mean I don't know that was one of those
I understand why anybody would go to
Vietnam on vacation they killed so many
of our she knew so many people that died
you know and I went back in 2014
Hanoi was my favorite it's French
tree-lined boulevards it's really the
lake that John McCain was shot down in
and the whole now has swan boats now has
now has Swan pedal boats no it doesn't I
told you that did you tell me that I did
tell you I was just using my Boston
background yeah you can rent couples go
there and and rent Swan paddle boats see
that's why I don't watch people stand-up
special because things stick years I
forget because I was sitting in oh I'm
gonna throw in the swans oak think from
we're watching cars right when I got
back so I went in 2014 this English guy
who runs the gig there in Hanoi also
gives motorcycle tours of the North in
Vietnam so I went back April of this
year and I went on this it was my my
dream to go on this motorcycle journey
and we were 45 miles north of Hanoi
going up a mountain a little winding
road and the bike went out from under me
and I wrecked
I wasn't saying how good a ride around
you I was gone forth time I've been on a
motorcycle and I've been afraid of
motorcycles my whole life so it was
something I wanted to do to break my
fear and the guy was wearing a helmet my
head bounced off the road but I was fine
and took a lot of skin off my elbow but
I think it just taken the safety course
out here we ride around a parking lot my
wife's brother my wife is from Holland
and her brother teaches motorcycle
lessons in Rotterdam so last summer when
I was in Rotterdam visiting her family
he took me out and and he and I did that
in the parking lot
okay so I did then how long between that
and then just riding up a [ __ ]
mountain in Vietnam what eight ten
months Lee I do this that's it I took my
ground school and didn't fly again in
eight months later I
setted the fly-in high dirtbike when I
was 14 and I like Tora tendon in my arm
and I missed a baseball season which was
a big deal when you're 14 yeah and and
then I didn't when I lived in Amsterdam
and I had the worked for this Dutch
Travel Show for a year I got to do a
highlight on Peru and we went to the
Nazca lines
you know those lines that people think
are alien landing strips they weren't
discovered until the 1920s that [ __ ] on
that cover that Zeppelin boxset really
dumb guy here dude I don't that's weird
you like talking English but half of
this [ __ ] you say I don't I don't I
don't know what that is I'm just this is
taking me back to high school
desert there's these desert drawings and
they weren't discovered until the 1920s
when aircraft was first flying over Peru
and one's a condor one's a monkey and
then they're look like these landing
strips in between it and yeah why would
you make it like that
if everyone didn't know how to fly back
that right is that would think they
asked it's like a thousand years old
it's how they have done it unless aliens
helped them maybe just maybe that's the
theater they developed some sort of hot
air balloon before anybody else and then
they all perished in some sort of plague
and they're you know if anything was
biodegradable back then how you gonna
find their hot air balloon okay it
doesn't always have to be aliens doesn't
yeah I used to do a align years ago that
the Incas did cocaine I guess that
explains why they were building a UFO
landing strips in the desert tell me
about a couple things I want to ask one
of my favorite podcast episodes ever
what was the one that you did with the
late great John Fox who was I never met
him but I heard all of the stories he
was like rode Viking I mean he like
every he created the cliches like the it
was kind of like the like I don't know
the Elvis or like you know in the early
days of rock and roll where there was no
you know go out go create it and create
what the [ __ ] this is gonna be and he
kind of did that as far as every [ __ ]
cliche now that guy was and listening to
that podcast with him because I'd only
heard of him and I never really you know
there's all these short little clips of
him on the internet just to get like an
hour an hour and ten minutes however
long it is of him telling stories and
then just hearing the stories in his
voice like that that crazy laugh voice
oh my god
oh my god like amazing how did you get
like everybody I like my buddy Paul
virzi met him and was like man that guy
was he was a [ __ ] sweetheart and
virzi madam right towards the end and he
actually knew they were working like
Milwaukee or something and he watched
his set and actually gave a couple of
tags encouraged him and all of that and
I don't know if he was sick yet but he
just was oh man he was like the nicest
guy and all of that type of stuff so I'm
so glad that you did that episode but
how did you get to meet John um I worked
with him when I was really young I think
I was I was nineteen when I worked with
him in Jacksonville Florida there used
to be a punch line there it was a great
room and nice to do my comedy zone down
there uh this is way before that you
know the the Atlanta punch line and the
in the boom and the late 80s there was
punch line comedy clubs all over the
south and the one in Jacksonville was
one of the best and and the guys that
owned it it was like four guys and then
they all got like Mercedes and BMWs and
then they were breaking in so much money
they moved it to a bigger venue they had
like a hundred and fifty seat room then
they moved it to a 500 seat room and the
place was never the same and it went out
of business but at one time that was
like one of the it was one of the
greatest clubs in the south so I worked
with him and you know John Fox was
legendary for kind of being a womanizer
coke freak booze hound all that Jan I
think he liked me
because I I could drink heavily and I I
was relatively cute and would attract
some laid-back some ladies
he still had he was on one of the first
through bed right right that is that is
next level like getting [ __ ] where it's
I just that remind me of Pedro Martinez
when he lost the heat on his fastball so
he developed a couple other pitches and
he was able to stay in the league at a
high level so he said they're crushing
ass cuz he was a good-looking guy when
he's young right
blonde hair had the mullet which was the
look the whole Miami Vice look he could
pull out was crush and ass and then all
of a sudden he starts to you know loses
a little heat on his fastball so he is a
good look you look in young fella I'll
bring him along they don't think
bringing the ladies up to the light here
that's the thing people don't don't
think of when they think of him when he
he was on one of those early Rodney
Dangerfield young comedian specials and
he looked like a California surfer guy
yeah he would blonde hair but he tan
he's a tan great shape no thing and then
he got older and pudgy and he looked
like an older white guy alcoholic dude
so the life caught up with him he helped
me get in he loved me and he helped me
get him with Chicago zany's where he was
the man you know that was his hometown
he was from Waukegan Illinois but he was
mr. Chicago so he gets me work with him
in Chicago booked like three weeks the
downtown room and a couple of the
suburban rooms for a couple of weeks I'm
19 I'd never been to Chicago and it was
sold out every night and he was demand
Seca one of his pornstar came and he
took me to the Blues Brothers had a bar
I'm doing cocaine after hours off the
the the pinball machine he took me he
took me to a Cubs game he took you under
his wing he took me under his wing but
it was great I mean America you know I'd
only be doing comedy for two years and
I'm in Chicago playing and sold-out
rooms opening for this guy but he took
me to see the Cubs and he was he was
kind of a Chicago celebrity back yeah
and he was buddies with Steve stone and
he actually took me up we got to go up
into the booth
when Harry Caray's sang take me out to
the ball game and like Harry Caray's
like you know half in the bag leaning
out the window and the don't hold his
belt so he didn't fall out
I mean who let a better life than that
guy gets to announce baseball while he's
just catching a buzz and everybody
started was hilarious that he was like
he was literally drunk yeah on the yeah
in the afternoon here so you know so I
mean you know John Fox was really nice
to me and I knew him through the years
and then the trials and tribulations and
bad relationships and years of booze and
excess it was kind of sad but I mean he
was kind of the cautionary tale of you
know you don't want to be this yeah Road
guy who is just chasing women and
partying and stuff forever because it it
was really a sad end for that guy and
then he lived in the apartment building
next door to the apartment where the
Zanies puts the comedian's in Chicago
it's an old town and there's the Old
Town Ale House which I remember him
taking me there and all these that area
in the in the late 80s was Graham a kid
and it was you know it was so much fun
and then he was kind of like sad lonely
drunk guy at the Old Town Ale House
towards the end what was towards the end
like when did it start becoming when did
it sort of shift where the industry
wasn't he stopped getting work and and I
I got the nice and white no I can't
remember right I can't remember a year I
did that recording with him I don't
think was the 90s because when I was no
no it was the early thousand yeah cuz
when I was in the 90s when I was
starting to get out there on the road it
was I would hear legendary stories about
him and then everywhere I had just been
it seemed Doug Stanhope was there and
had some sort of debauchery in the
[ __ ] green room you know I remember
the first time I met Doug Stanhope
you know I instantly loved the guy
but before I met him I was like who the
[ __ ] is this Stanhope guy what a [ __ ]
he you know do all this [ __ ] outside of
the goddamn the comedy condo and but I
would always hear like oh my god the
Atlanta punchline they they used to have
stories I know there's a couple of guys
who are still alive so I don't know
[ __ ] put this [ __ ] out there but
there was like a couple of guys on that
Mount Rushmore of like the waitstaff
would be so excited that they were
coming to town and after like maybe a
night and a half like that Sunday night
show seemed like three years away and
they were just like I don't think I'm
gonna make it because there was those
guys that came to town and they just
they would like this Pied Piper and the
entire [ __ ] waitstaff they had this
charisma all the bartenders the club
owners they he would just take him on a
crawl night after night after [ __ ]
night yeah and and like I mean I this
other guy that I know of well I'm not
gonna mention his name like he had a
nickname and all that and he would pick
up the phone and he would just he would
say a name like Tom you like Antibes
it's so-and-so and the running joke was
you would just scream in horror knowing
that he was coming to town he was going
to stay with you and that you guys were
going to be hitting a bottle of - every
it would be like trying to keep up with
Lemmy some of these guys it reminds me
of someone like the Lemmy Motorhead
stories that you hear him so yeah but
when you don't have the the albums and
the following to fall back on
like I remember anything John Fox when
he was still like surfer a good-looking
guy I remember he would walk by the
waitress station and he would go
he would just announce [ __ ] me before
I'm famous he would say that out loud to
the he never would have survived the my
god Wow but so when he was so towards
the end and you know and I always had a
soft spot from heart for the guy because
he helped me when I was a young comedian
and so I did that interview with him and
the thing that I that stands out for me
on that interview that I did with him oh
so there was there was one when when it
got sad for him I remember there was
some
turbulent relationship he was in and and
he was falling apart and as as an
alcoholic and he's in this terrible
relationship and the girl had scratched
his face like really bad and so he had
all these scratch marks on his face and
there was a story in Atlanta about him
breaking down onstage and crying and
just some really sad stories and [ __ ]
that happened to him but the thing that
saying it's a [ __ ] movie yeah the
thing that stands out for me about that
interview was that he still believed in
love he's talking about and he had been
through all this [ __ ] in his life and
you know he's he's older pudgy alcoholic
guy past his prime and he's still
talking about love and it's like Raging
Bull but the stand-up version like an
arrow back in the day cookie could have
played John Fox like the John Fox story
it's the same thing and in the end he
ends up doing stand-up in Raging Bull
yeah Jesus Christ well you uh you you
cleaned up your act how long ago I've
been sober for almost five years that's
[ __ ] amazing I've been I finally kind
of cleaned up my act I don't like I
don't think I would ever not do it again
but like I drank like the last day of
June and then I drank August 7th and I'm
not gonna drink again select October and
now I sort of drink like the way I smoke
cigars or I should say the way I would
like to smoke cigars which I've liked it
a couple times a month or every other
month or something like that you know
I'm I'm trying like you know I got a kid
I'm a super old [ __ ] dad they have a
kid so it's just like I have to [ __ ]
be around until this my kid has it
figured out you know every every warrior
needs to move on two wise men
yeah well I can't be out pound in it and
one of the greatest things ever happened
to me was giving up the booze and I mean
and I feasted from the banquet of life
you know I live in Amsterdam
you know I hosted a talk-show over
London you would like the Dave Letterman
chauffeured for two years on Dutch
television but
you know I went through some pretty
hardcore tragedies my dad who I adored
was killed by a drunk driver in 2009
through the irony of that when you see
that helmet that surviving Vietnam all
of that and the medals and all that and
then just some jackass and Anaheim which
ain't no we've all [ __ ] done so I
can't like it's just [ __ ]
unbelievable again and then my little
sister who I was really close with died
of breast cancer in 2011 my wife and I
actually got married at her hospital
bedside the day before she died of
cancer because I didn't want her to miss
it so that was 2011 so 2012 2013 I had
stopped drinking for pleasure numbing
myself because I'm ya heart broken and
then January 1st 2014 in Philadelphia I
blacked out and busted my head open and
the next I got like six stitches on my
forehead at a black eye the next day I
looked in the mirror and I saw so much
ugliness and and I knew it I knew you
know that was the moment when you look
at I mean I had been thinking about it
and I just thought the main I mean
vanity was was a big reason because I
saw so much ugliness in the mirror but
also I knew it was holding me back as a
comedian I knew I could be a better
comedian if I stopped drinking every
night and you know and I didn't go to
any AAA meetings which AAA people always
get offended when I say that but I just
I just had had enough and the first
first couple weeks you know you're a
little little bumpy but you know you can
get through it just pictured you looking
in the mirror with your black eye and
the cut and just being like alright you
went yeah I'm not [ __ ] doing this
well what happened was I looked in the
mirror and I just thought I want to go
one year when I looked in the mirror
what I said to myself was I want to go
one year and see what it's like not
being drunk every night to be to see
what I could get done and I got so much
done
writing jokes and you know working on my
book in different projects and stuff I
have I that's what made me stick yeah
oh my into having a kid now - it's like
is every every dad told me said oh yeah
I have a kit that'll dental curb your
drinking because they don't give a [ __ ]
or have any sort of concept of what
being hungover is yeah and they wake up
with like they're they're on a full tank
like the whole body is brand-new nothing
hurts and they're ready to just it's
just like that they get right in your
face
hi yelling and [ __ ] is just like it's
actually you know I'm finding if I'm
gonna go out and do stand-up I have to
make the I have to be out the door by 8
o'clock 8:05 I I'm gonna fall asleep
it's just one of those things like she
gets up at like a quarter to 7:00 in the
morning and that happened to me last
night where I was like I'm gonna go out
I think was actually I was gonna go see
Mission Impossible because I want to
watch Tom Cruise speaking of helicopters
flying that helicopter and I just oh the
next showing isn't until 10 or 10:30 and
I knew I was like I'm gonna fall asleep
in the middle of Mission Impossible Tom
Cruise action summer action movie I am
so [ __ ] tired I'm gonna fall asleep
so plus I want to take my knee along to
go see it in like IMAX get the whole
thing before the whole experience before
it goes away so let let me see yeah
let's splits promotes they're gonna be
in Mongolia what else do you got like I
don't know if I have any listeners there
that was such a great story about the
house supported the comics were because
I did a gig in India in like most of the
crowd was comedians I was so happy that
I didn't realize that because that would
have been like intimidated like that god
they're all gonna be like what's next
joke structure and remember afterwards
we all hung out and it was like it was
weird it was like I was hanging at a
comedy club on the other side of the
world in like total they're cold but it
was the exact same [ __ ] questions did
you write on stage you do that yeah
don't you think this guy's overrated
they would say [ __ ] like that was like
oh my god it's the exact same for the
guys they're probably over there
emulating your gestures and stuff cuz
they hung out
no but I actually do what I found was
people in India are [ __ ] hilarious
they're just they're a they're it's kind
of that same vibe of like when you go to
Ireland and Scotland where you just meet
like you'd like yeah there's what I love
the most like a commentary the the you
know the fraternity of it you know yeah
they're like people in Australia funny
they're just [ __ ] funny I don't know
what it is and another place as you go
I'm not gonna mentions I'm gonna [ __ ] on
any he just go and they're just like
these people are polite and then you go
to these other places it's just like he
just is the second you walk into the
airport you just start seeing characters
that guys it's gonna be a good show
these people are cool so oh and I'm so
glad you went to that that store in
Paris and on your podcast yeah you
wouldn't give the name of it oh yeah
because I turned you into it why do I
live email because I was picturing you
going there the next time standing in
this line you know you're all excited
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] bill set it on
this podcast not gonna stand in but this
already the word is kind of people
already know and when people come up to
me I tell them like like what it is and
I actually like the sandwiches better if
the sandwiches are amazing remember what
I what I told you what I tell everybody
get one of the sandwiches because
they're incredible and then buy one for
later from when you're walking around
Paris and you think to yourself damn I
wish I'd have bought a but another say
for later
you guys know it doesn't overdo it it
doesn't just makes you want to keep
going back so you know a lot of that
Mission Impossible I heard is it's very
it's shot in Paris yeah I gotta check
that out but I keep trying to get to
your date say okay alright a funny bone
in Mongolia no no no that's called the
you be the OL on guitar is called they
call it ub city so it's the ub city
comedy club okay so the checked out this
schedule I have for the rest of the year
August 22nd um in ulaanbataar Mongolia
August 24th I'm in Beijing China August
25th Shanghai August 30th through
September 2nd um
at levity live in West Nyack New York
are you driving to these gigs
no wait you're doing so you're doing
this quick little it's that's not even
Southeast Asia that's that's yeah you
know I did Southeast Asia in April of
course this is a Maharajah butterfly it
sounds a couple of gigs so I could have
an excuse to go back to Mongolia and
summer and check it out you know so
September 4th through the 9th amid
zany's in Chicago 12th through the 16th
I'm in Rosemont at Zanies September 27th
through September 30th I'm at the
punchline in Atlanta I love that place
October 4th I'm in porto portugal doing
a comedy festival as you do October 6th
lisbon october 12th and 13th paris the
16th through the 20th is oslo the 25th
through the 28th always are funny
[ __ ] people
I love Oslo yeah it's great they're
really like they're fun [ __ ] people I
think it's my favorite place in
Scandinavia 25th of the 29th Galway
Ireland doing that comedy festival and
that's your potential anywhere in the
world you told me that I would live in
Galway yes one of my favorite places in
the world the 31st is Dublin November
1st is Belfast November 3rd Berlin you
know this is why you such a [ __ ]
interesting get you were the most
interesting people I've ever met because
how do you not you know well I guess
there are mouth-breathing morons that
could travel this way and lost
everything sorry with [ __ ] in their
worldview wouldn't [ __ ] change but
yours does thankfully I'm interrupting
here continue what uh yeah but you know
I was trying to make that show where I
would be the Anthony Bourdain of comedy
but whatever may be November 8th to the
11th I'm at The Improv and Addyson the
November 12 through 18 Las Vegas
November 23rd through 27 Tokyo Japan
what's you have Rosen cinema but The
Improv in Pittsburgh I'm actually really
excited about my why did you sleep no
I've never been to Pittsburgh so she
used to travel with me everywhere and
now she's selective where she wants to
go
wants to go to Pittsburgh because we've
never seen it I can tell you you gotta
get there was a perm a nice you got to
get one of those sandwiches yeah they're
Italian section with all the the
gabagool and all that [ __ ] Joe bartnik
and virzi brought me through the oh they
they went and got it
through Pittsburgh is one of the great
cities this country has it's one of the
great the home base in America I've
never performed one of the go to a
Pirates game that view with the bridges
it's it's unbelievable it's one of my
favorite cities and when you come from
the airport it's the greatest skyline
you're gonna see because it's not like
you see it it just keeps getting bigger
and bigger you can't see it at all and
then you drive through like this [ __ ]
Hill this tunnel and then you come out
and just boom it's this panoramic it's
like all of these bridges there's the
ballpark's and everything to the left
Heinz Field but the Pirates play its
gonna say Pacbell it's where the Giants
used to play I figured what the [ __ ]
they call it they change them every year
and then then the skyscrapers and though
they they just there's so much to do
there the food is unbelievable and the
you should be like Billy Stargell you
should give out little stars for
comedians that way if ever he used to do
that what do willie stargell in 1979
they called him pops yeah and they had
those there's flat hats back then yep
the old way he used to give out little
stars to the his teammates that he
thought whenever they did something
great alright so in the back of their
hats they had all these stars you
remember that yeah vaguely Kenta Colton
it was like a really cool thing about
them I saw him one at one of the last
time one of his last public experience
and to convey the sidearm throw no
appearances I saw yeah but I saw Willie
Stargell when he was old he was sick you
could tell he was dying and I was at
Three Rivers Stadium and I was watching
the Cubs first the Pirates Sammy Sosa
was still out in right field he still
looked Cubans you know before have you
seen him now no he's whiter than oh yeah
you know yeah there was some big story
about him yeah I read recently yeah he's
always living in Dubai and he's
he looks yeah he looks like John Fox
yeah yeah that's what Sammy Sosa looks
like okay so yeah what Pittsburgh
November 29 through December 2nd I don't
think the Pirates will be playing then
okay we wrote Heinz Field and then
December 10th through the 17th I'm in
Israel doing this Israel tour and then
we're having to remember 20th through
the 22nd I'm at The Improv in Orlando
Madagascar what do we get I've never
been Antarctica
I've never the only cut I've not the
only continents I have not performed on
is Africa and Antarctica okay yeah dude
there's got to be some sort of
expedition so the man out there right
now the comedy igloo as soon as that
opens when the yes 40th anniversary of
the thing when they when they all go
down there you got to uh you got to get
that thing I think I'm gonna dial back
the International Travel next year well
I I do it is I overdue to go go to
Australia and I just sort of like as I
get the new hour I just have it in my
head where what hour I did the last time
I was there and I always go and have a
great time it's a lot weirder now that I
have a kid so we set up this east of
Australia it's his Sydney's one of my
favorite cities in the world
all of those cities are great Brisbane
Melbourne Perth yeah I came to Perth on
Australia Day [ __ ] lunatics who do
the El Camino was still popular so
popular they love those [ __ ] things
yeah that what's that I figured what
they call it that it's a I remember
going to Australia for the first time
I'm like what kind of car is that
there's this this automobile brand
called Holden and they still make those
El Camino minotaurs they're great yeah
and people get more [ __ ] shit-faced
drive it all around I've told you this
[ __ ] I said I went to bon Scott's grave
and something I went to Bon Scott
somebody had a Miller Genuine Draft
bottle on there and I wanted to remove
it but I was like I'll out of respect
for the person that put it there and
bought probably drank it he wouldn't
give a [ __ ] yeah but all right let's uh
let's wrap this up here so I just got to
say you you're one of my favorite people
one of my favorite
comedians and this has been one of the
best podcasts I've done as far as just
like fascinating [ __ ] stole I mean
everything we had life death here what
do you say heroic behavior heroism is
that a word
heroism heroism yeah I've been to a lot
of countries too and it just doesn't
seem to mix on hey man I thanks for
having me man I you're one of my
favorite people to hang out with every
time you and I get together and we just
like hang out as buddies I always get
material out of it you know I was
telling you that story about because I
pronounced so many words incorrectly I
was just saying I can't imagine how many
how many [ __ ] countries I've been to
and I still sound like I've never left
my block this is a great I was telling
you about arguing with my wife because
she wants me to clean the toilet and
like I don't I don't want to clean the
toilet right and you know a lot of
thoughts go through my head during the
day you know watch a movie sleep on the
couch call a friend cleaning the toilet
is not one of them and we live in an
apartment building so this is what it's
like to argue in an apartment building
you make a valid point now lower your
voice yeah because I don't want
everybody in my building knowing my
business I'm in the laundry room folding
clothes some guy walks in there I know
you you're the dude you don't lean the
toilet I just started doing that again
the last two weeks and that comes from
having a conversation with you on my
balcony smoking cigarette or cigar yeah
you're one of those guys you're always
spitting out material you don't realize
it you gotta go don't waste that on me
you but it did yeah I see an argument
name was still living in an apartment we
used to uh she didn't give a [ __ ] and
she calls it she's passionate so this is
when she would occasionally throw [ __ ]
at me or punch me in the chest this is
back her younger Wilder days and I
remember we would get into and I would
lose so many arguments because she
didn't give a [ __ ] about volume and I
would always be going like all right
deactivate to point you don't kind of
help the whole [ __ ] world know about
it I said they get out so then what's
worse is you start whispering so only
your [ __ ] is coming out and all the
neighbors like oh my god he's horrible
he's not even
arguing she's so [ __ ] right that's
where they get you when they call out on
you
well anyways so great you finally came
on finally got you on I think it's
because we also love smoking cigars and
telling stories so it's like why would
we have a podcast get in the way of that
I'm so glad you came on you got to
promote your dates here so go semen
Mongolia
if not you can see him in Pittsburgh
Atlanta yeah West Nyack in Orlando yes
you know I still I still play everywhere
all over the states time you know and
you have a great life I majored in like
radio communication where you got a
great radio I wish somebody would give
me a voice over gigs huh you know this
town is you gotta take it running
through the grass on my tippy toes there
you go
definitely check him out he's going to
be everywhere and if he's gonna travel
that [ __ ] far you can travel a little
bit to go see him the great Tom Rhodes
everybody thank you so much for coming
on here's a little music for you and
then we get we have a bonus half hour of
greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon
podcast from earlier this year or years
ago I don't know I don't decide all
right have a great weekend you [ __ ] and
I'll talk to you on Monday
you